distribution is the process by which a
medication is carried to its Target
tissue or site of action with the goal
of causing a therapeutic response this
process follows medication absorption
and predes medication
metabolism medication is first carried
to highly vascularized tissues including
the
liver
heart
kidneys
and
brain then medication is widely
circulated within the body reaching
areas of less extensive blood supply
such as Skin muscle and
fat medication then accumulates in the
fat and in poorly vascularized tissues
like bone especially if the medication
is lipophilic or strongly attracted to
lipids
in the
blood some medication molecules bind to
plasma proteins to which they are
attracted in this bound State medication
molecules are unable to produce a
pharmacological
effect in Bound and Unbound form the
medication flows through the arteries
and into
capillaries capillaries carry the
medication close to the tissue's cells
where hydrostatic pressure drives
molecules between the capillary
endothelial cells into the interstitial
space some protein bound macro molecules
are too large to pass through the vessel
walls so they never reach the target
tissue Unbound or free molecules do
reach the target tissue by exiting the
bloodstream between the loose Junctions
in the capillary endothelium into the
interstitial space to interact with the
tissue
cells some molecules bind to the cells
While others remain in the extracellular
fluid the interaction of the Unbound
medication with the target tissue
results in a therapeutic
response there are many factors s that
affect
distribution for example the effect of
membrane permeability on distribution
can be demonstrated in the
brain the brain's capillaries are
impermeable to the majority of
medications due to the blood brain
barrier a membrane that blocks the
entrance of both toxic and therapeutic
substances into brain
tissues
some medications penetrate the blood
brain barrier based on features like low
polarity and high solubility in
lipids fat soluble molecules cross cell
membranes faster than water soluble
molecules due to the lipophilic nature
and phospholipid composition of the
cellular membrane
factors such as body fat percentage and
disease also affect medication
distribution fat deposits retain lipid
soluble unionized medication and release
the molecules over
time thus obese patients may experience
prolonged pharmacologic
effects inflammation disease and
injuries such as Burns can alter protein
levels and thus medication
binding increasing capillary
permeability and uptake in cells and
tissues as a complication of kidney
disease albumin cannot bind medications
effectively resulting in a low
percentage of protein bound
medication these shifts result in high
levels of free medication circulating
throughout the body